زمان من الغله ان كان جو الليل
في الارض
بنشتغل فيها انا عانات كثير من اليهود انا
كان عندي دفائات وعندي بيتك عند الرفور
الحمد لله بعد ما تجيب بعد ما زرعته وجدبت
الزراعه يعني والحمد لله يعني هينا امبارح
كان عندي يعني زيتون الحمد لله كثير بصير
اطلاق نار
بس تكون على الحدود ابو 100 متر عن الحدود
تاع اليهود انا واولادي وحفايدي
والله حياتنا يا بنيه صعبه صعبه يعني
عايشين بالخوف وعايشين
بالرعب مش الواحد بده يسوي على العيشه
المره للقمر منه بقى
نقعد فيها ونستقر
معاناتنا الاولى والاخيره انه بنيجي بنزرع
الزرع منها ووقت اثمارها بيجي للجيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي جرافاته فبتخدم لنا
كل اللي احنا زرعناه وباليوم الثاني
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي بيطلق النار علينا من
كل يوم صباح وكل يوم مساء
واحيانا يطلق طيران برش كل الاراضي
الزراعيه
الحدود قطاع غزه عشان تحرق كل الارض
الزراعيه بمبيدات حارقه للاعشاب حارقها
للنباتات
عزيزتون تحبك وذاتوني تعرفي
وهذه المنطقه هذه رحلت منها بقول لك في
2009 جربوني اليهود ثلاث مرات
وبعدين ما رضيش الناس كل يوم واحنا راحلين
وكل يوم واحنا مشتتين
انا انولدت في الارض هذه وعايشه فيها وانا
باعشق الزراعه وبالنسبه للارض انا بتمثل
لي يعني هي نبضات قلب الارض انا بحس فيها
لما ما اكونش فيها قلبي ما بينبض بس وانا
فيها القلب نبض وشغال والحمد لله